I love talking business. I love helping people make money because it helps me make money.
Okay. I'm not the philanthropist. I'm not the guy that's going to say I like to help people.
I like to help people make money because that's how I make money. So let's just clear that out of
the way. But what I want to share with you really quickly to give you a little bit of confidence
that you did make the right decision and I do want to thank you and tell you right now
that I will make sure that you get far more value than you will ever spend with me. That is my
commitment to you because I know how this works. I know that I need to help you get deals. You're
here for one reason and that is to make money. You are here to get deals and if I can help you
get deals, I'm therefore going to make money. Okay. But I want to give you a little bit of
confidence and say this does work and I'm not talking about the case studies, which is social
proof. I want to just tell you how this came to be really quickly. This is not something that a
couple of months ago I sat down and went, you know what? There's a huge opportunity to make money
and I'm going to develop this system and I'm going to sell it. No, what happened was in 2019,
as you guys may or may not know, I was $60,000 in debt. I had two cars. I lived in a different
house. I had a house payment. I had three kids and I had a really upset wife who didn't even
know about that debt. I sat down and I looked at my situation and I looked at my goals and I was
like, I want to make $100,000 a month. I can't do this. I can't work for somebody else. I have to
own the thing. I have to own the business. I had been doing some version of a digital agency for
years and years and years and I couldn't scale. What this is, what you're about to watch, what
Flat Fee Mastery is, is it is the product of how I was able to go from a situation that was very
dire to doing seven figures in a 12-month period. That is what this is. This is something that came,
this was the solution to my problems. This is the solution to how do I scale up and hit the
$100,000 per month goal that I had set for myself and that is how this came. I want to make sure
that you understand this did not come as a way to make money. This came because I needed to get
out of that really terrible situation and I figured out this thing called results in advance
and this thing called running ads to a landing page and all these different little pieces of
the puzzle and I started testing and I started tweaking and I started refining and I developed
this process. I just want you to know that the reason that I can assure you that this works is
yeah forget about the case studies, forget about all the people that I've already shown
you that have tried this and made this work but this is exactly what I used to get out of my
situation that was the catalyst to get me to where I am today. I believe the best products are those
that were made as solutions. There were those that were made to solve problems, not the ones
that were created, not products that were created just to make money and I'll tell you
that this what you're about to jump into, what you're about to see, what you're about to go
through was the solution that I came up with to my problems.